[Music]
my celebrity look-alike
well I'm tagged on Facebook in five I
think five places as your boy g-unit 50
cent hey it's the truth
I don't know if I believe it but that's
what people tag down nothing more I'm
more of a Morris Chestnut type you know
myself especially the cheekbones but I
don't know some people say I look like
the guy from Twilight Jacob Taylor
Lautner maybe young Hillary Clinton you
just love me look like Matt Damon this
guy told me that I look like Seth Rogen
people say Kim Kardashian but I don't
see it whatsoever people tell me I look
like roshon fegan I don't think
I get Michelle Rodriguez a lot there
remember Bad Santa
a lot of people tell me a young meryl
streep
I've been told by many people very close
friends when they miss me that they
tuned into what not to wear who was
hosted by Clinton Kelly who I have to
agree I cannot deny a remarkable
resemblance to I get all the time that I
look like Zac Efron and Jared Leto for
like a younger version and not a beard
she will donate in Anne Hathaway a lot
of people tell me on a really bad day I
look like Kurt Cobain
that's where I met I used to get teased
the middle school that I look like
Justin Bieber I've been told I look like
Sam sparks from potty with a Chance of
Meatballs but when I have my glasses on
so Alfonzo barrel calls in some Fresh
Prince of bel-air
yeah
I would say my celebrity look-alike is
probably JK Rowling I've been told
Hilary Duff some people tell me I look
like Rockefeller 35 I look like mr. bean
in the olden days it would be Tina Fey
from SNL I get Naya Rivera Jesse Tyler
Ferguson but I look a little different
now some work long people tell me that I
look like Olivia Munn and I don't think
I look like Libya mom cuz Olivia Munn is
way prettier than I am but I get that
frequently Christopher Walken when I'm
old I've insisted on it and a few people
have the grudgingly agree I think Don
Cheadle
I feel like my soul every local I would
be Kanye West probably
I've been told Alicia Keys but I've also
been told Jada pinkett-smith Jordin
Sparks
my celebrity look like I would honestly
have to say either Donald Walker or
Leonardo DiCaprio at least douchey way
possible so I've been told by a couple
people that I look like Britney Spears
where or is that what you want to live
yeah bye bye a waiter in Europe he told
me well they say item driver and my
girlfriend says Christian Bale celebrity
look like is Anton Yelchin celebrity
lookalikes I've been told is River
Phoenix and Johnny Depp my celebrity
look-alikes are Jaden Smith
I get Enrique Iglesias and Zac Efron
hello every look like Bruno Mars
he told when I was younger I looked a
little like Shark Boy along Taylor and
basically hey Jeff Gillooly dig up
dinosaurs
I look like Mariah Carey if I'm really
dark and has straight hair
I think Taylor Swift people have told me
I look like Priyanka Chopra cat fitting
from supergirls
well according to my YouTube comments
I look like Rosa Diaz from Brooklyn
nine-nine Ali McGraw
Debbie Ryan
Lauren London my celebrity look-alike is
the dude from angel like the Buffy in
the vampire show
I don't know its name you know talk
about yeah yeah
skinny Jonah Hill oh okay well the past
people thought I look like a robot Tara
Ramirez plays Callie Torres are very
Batman for Easter
hi Carly a whimsy Lohan Noah Cyrus well
my celebrity look-alike is Peter
Sarsgaard
Oh Gavin and where are you from Bay Area
cool and utility look like I am a
celebrity but Facebook's not doing too
well these days
well add the belt next to it so you get
notified every time I put it up so thank
you guys again for everything
[Music]